we have
very
very bad news for republican congressman
matt gates
we have now
heard
that matt gates was told
matt
you had sex with a minor she's under 18.
uh the broader context here
is this investigation that's now been
going on for we've known about it for
about 10 months into republican trumpian
congressman matt gates
who is being investigated for a whole
bunch of different things including
possibly having sex with a minor
um sometimes we call that statutory rape
uh trafficking sex trafficking of a
minor across state lines
potentially paying people for sex
there's all these different things he's
denied everything and has lawyered up
with some of the best sex crimes defense
attorneys and one of the questions has
been
is he sort of like a bystander here and
he wasn't ever even really told hey some
of the stuff you're doing might not be
okay
there is an incredible blockbuster piece
of information now as the daily beast is
reporting witness can confirm matt gates
was told he had sex with a minor one of
the key interactions joel greenberg this
is like his wingman
claims to have had with matt gates is a
phone call informing gates they'd been
sleeping with a minor
someone witnessed the call meaning it is
not only greenberg that says this call
took place there's a witness that now
corroborates it
here's the detail on september 4 2017
according to his confession letter joel
greenberg called his friend matt gates
with some bad news
the teenager both men paid to have sex
with was underage greenberg claimed
now two sources tell the daily beast
a cooperating witness can confirm
details of that call for one damning
reason
he was in greenberg's office when the
call took place
the witness big joe ellicott greenberg's
longtime best friend and an employee at
the seminole county tax office recently
pleaded guilty to fraud and drug charges
as part of a cooperation agreement
although ellicott has so far avoided
charges regarding sex trafficking of a
minor which greenberg pleaded guilty to
last may he was present for the call
that greenberg made to gates on
september 4th according to two people
the call they said was short and gates
was the one who ended it
um
this uh and and here is the specifics
immediately i called the congressman and
warned him to stay clear of this person
and informed him she was under age gates
was equally shocked and disturbed there
was no further contact with this
individual
until after her 18th birthday this is
just absolutely incredible now of course
investigators aren't stupid they are
going to look at phone records and i'm
sure already have to see if there is
such a call that took place between
greenberg and gates on september 4th of
2017 but we now have a witness to the
call greenberg and the witness both are
saying this call took place and this is
looking worse and worse for matt gates
now do we know if charges will be
brought no we don't know that
a lot of this comes to what can you
prove
um do we know
whether uh there were other such
instances where gates was repeatedly
told about the underage reality of this
woman we just don't have all of the
information but what do we know we are
10 months in and the investigation
hasn't ended
um
gates's wingman is cooperating and has
pleaded guilty there is a cooperation
agreement for another individual
associated with the entire thing and
there are now specific assertions being
made that it wasn't just that it just so
happened that this is what took place
with gates gates was told that this is
what took place so
if i had to guess
this isn't going away anytime soon and
specifically if and when what particular
charges will be brought again against
gates we just don't know
we'll have a link to this article and
more information on our instagram which
you can find at davidpakmanshow you can
also follow me on instagram david.pacman